importante pero insuficiente
en eeuu así es como los activistas han
descrito un nuevo acuerdo entre
demócratas y republicanos sobre el
control de armas de fuego el paquete de
medidas que requiere una mayoría para
ser aprobado por el senado incluye un
incentivo para que los estados se
retiren las armas a las personas
consideradas peligrosas un reforzamiento
de la comprobación de los antecedentes
penales y psicológicos de los
compradores de 18 a 21 años y la
financiación de diversos programas de
salud mental pero estas medidas no
incluyen el grueso de las reformas que
los demócratas han estado pidiendo y
muchos activistas las tildaron de
inadecuadas por ejemplo el proyecto de
reformas no incluye la prohibición de
las armas semiautomáticas la prohibición
de los cargadores de gran capacidad la
edad mínima de 21 años para comprar
rifles tipo ar-15 y la verificación
universal de los antecedentes de los
compradores sin embargo el presidente d
los sonidos se felicitó de que los
avances sean importantes
no hace todo lo que creo que es
necesario pero refleja pasos importantes
en la dirección correcta la presencia de
10 senadores republicanos entre los
firmantes del acuerdo sugiere que tiene
posibilidades reales de ser aprobado por
el senado el sábado 11 de julio miles de
estadounidenses se manifestaron para
pedir un mayor control de las armas tras
recientes tiroteos que dejaron decenas
de muertos